hi I am Peter Herman and I'm here at
BuzzFeed to read and respond to your
very thirsty tweets alright here we go
I had three dreams last night about
Peter Herman I never thought my next
celebrity rivalry would be Mariska
Hargitay I will say this
you'll lose hands now no question and
then my follow up is just what were the
dreams but we can do that offline my god
look at this you've sent this at 11 a.m.
you're tweeting about me at 11 a.m. get
back to work so when is my very own
Peter Herman going to walk into my life
very very very soon
your very own to have and to hold and to
be incredibly thirsty about now we have
to do is in a German accent right leave
it to Peter hummin to make German and
sexy language I just Agni mad danca that
is our sweet bean hats leaking tank just
everybody everybody's good-looking it
doesn't sound sexy
alright here we go I'd like to thank at
younger TV for all the half-naked Peter
Herman content really doing God's work
I think that is a fairly broad
interpretation of gut of what God's work
is on this earth but I feel very honored
that I can be a part of spreading that
particular message god bless I want to
lick Peter Herman's abs so thank you for
that the next time they get dirty I'll
know who to call just the morning
thought Peter Herman with his gray hair
and and green eyes he's just so sexy
he's not the weight of my heart my wife
at least calls it salt and pepper which
I think at this point might be being
generous Wow Peter Herman with his gray
hair I'm taking this one home I'm
showing this one to brush girl she
laughed
I want to lick Peter Herman's face but
she adds this has the odd like Peter
Hermits of eighth period respectfully
here I would only have you do it
respectfully and I would respectfully
receive your licking Maggie says Peter
Herman is so hot and then thank you for
coming to my TED talk oh that's her TED
talk that's really funny
that is a fantastically efficient TED
talk because people actually want it
shorter than 20 minutes
finally like the two and a half second
TED talk because that's the only
attention span that anybody has anyway
Peter her father husband actor author
photographer Baker barista he just looks
like he cooks a perfect steak probably
flies to heaven at night with his huge
wings because he's literally an angel
not being a millennial I don't know what
he just looks like he cooks a perfect
steak actually means if that is a
euphemism or if it's just about cooking
a perfect steak thank you that you think
I cook a perfect steak maybe we need to
cook steak together i watch younger
because Peter Herman is a babe in all
caps so she so you yelled that I
understand that please sir come take me
all right and I like the fact that your
profile picture is a picture of my wife
which is not not that it's not the first
one imagine I'm like this you do not
want this world imagine a world where
all men were Peter Herman hmm trust me
one's enough you're mad because she said
a prince charming where's my Peter
Herman and I say absolutely I think he's
coming I think he's on the way this is
this is literally quite literally the
bottom of the barrel Lauren I'm puzzled
by your format I'm just puzzled by your
format it's Peter Herman Peter Herman :
and I get to say nothing I'm gonna go to
the writers room and I have an issue
with that fact that you got all the
lines a and B yours your it is your your
in all caps so you're yelling oh my god
I love you you're so cute oh and I want
to make sure I love this I want to make
sure you're always protected and happy I
love one man only you deserve the world
I'm and this is fantastic I'm crying
SHS a which I think that you at the
means at the end of your yelling you
deteriorate just into a puddle of
deep affection for me I couldn't be more
grateful
or perhaps thirst which is also nice but
maybe now I'm thirsty very very thirsty
thank you this has been thirsty it has
been fun thank you for for thirsting
with me make sure you watch the
thirstiest show out there younger 10:00
p.m. Wednesdays on TV land bye
[Music]
you